les travaux avancent à vue d'oeil et le
jour comme la nuit à l'image de la chine
c'est au tour de la russie de construire
un hôpital en un temps record en
banlieue de sa capitale
nous construisons 56 moeurs entièrement
dédié au traitement des patients qui
seront infectées a dit le maire adjoint
la russie qui prétendait et semblait du
moins sur papier l'avoir échappé belle
envisage désormais le pire offre duo
putsch son scénario catastrophique
le docteur en chef de cet hôpital privé
[Musique]
c'est tout comme si le pays sortait de
sa bulle pour la première fois les
bulletins de nouvelles
entre dans les foyers en prêchant par
l'exemple ci dit mme thomas des
animateurs vedettes qui diffuse même
leur appartement pour prouver qu'il est
possible de travailler à la maison car
jusqu'ici les russes ont été difficiles
à convaincre les programmes de
livraisons à domicile ont été organisées
d'urgence pour les aînés qui sont
dorénavant obligés de se cloîtrer leur
président qui il ya une semaine à peine
des crimes et la situation comme étant
sous contrôle a décrété une semaine de
congés payés pour toute la population
les parcs les commerces tout est fermé
jusqu'au 5 avril
notre ministre il faudra deux ou trois
mois pour traverser la tempête a ajouté
le président poutine avec son calme
habituel avant de s'enfermer pour une
réunion du g20 au cours de laquelle il a
plaidé en faveur d'un moratoire sur les
centres
il faut créer des corridors verts pour
les changes de médicaments et de
matériel
c'est une question de vie ou de mort
selon lui et même l'armée russe est
désormais mise à contribution dans cette
guerre sanitaire sans précédent des
exercices sont en cours pour tester les
capacités des troupes de désinfecter des
villages entre 6 nécessaire mais pour
moscou il semble être déjà trop tard
nous allons passer au travers peut-on
lire sur un des plus hauts gratte ciel
de la ville tandis que des rumeurs d'un
couvre-feu circulent ici tamara alter
escaut radio canada mon rêve